The Saudi bank failed to rule
out giving funding to the
already embattled company that
combined with the recent U.S.
Issue sent stocks falling.
I want to bring in business
reporter rahel Solomon, rahel,
walk us through what happened
today.
>> Well, Jake, basically the
mood for investors, as investors
search for the next sign of
weakness.
To be clear, I think the NASDAQ
actually closed slightly higher
which is interesting.
But this is really just a
confidence issue at this point.
You can see that reflected very
clearly in some of the bank
stocks.
I want to point your attention
to some of the regional stocks,
Jake, you and I have talked
about already.
First republic bank off 21%,
pac-west off 5% on top of the
losses.
It's been a rough go for some of
the regional stocks as we face
the confidence issue in banking.
But some of the larger banks
getting swept up in the selloff.
Chase was off earlier bank of
America, citigroup, Wells Fargo
getting caught up in the larger.
And Chase Bank it's been
considered the problem child of
European banking, so it had its
fair share of issues even before
svb's collapse and signature.
I think what we're witnessing
how on edge investors are about
the sector and banking outlook
and really confidence issues
moving forward.
>> The situation regulator just
put out a statement trying to
shore up confidence in credit
Suisse.
What did they say?
And might that work?
>> Well that is the big
question, right, this comment,
this statement coming out about
30 minutes ago from Swiss
regulators essentially from the
smb and the signature bank,
I.e., svb do not pose a risk for
the financial markets.
Here's what's perhaps most
important, Jake.
Credit Suisse meets the requires
on requirements imposed, it
looks called but the most
important thing.
If necessary, the Swiss bank
will provide with liquidity.
You're getting assurances there
with the national bank much like
we saw with the federal reserve.
>> Rahal, thank you for that.
Phil Mattingly joins us live.
Phil, you've been speaking to
officials at the U.S.
Treasuretry department.
What's their plan?
>> What rahel just read off
track what is officials are
trying to make clear throughout
the course of this day.
And that is the fact what
happened over the weekend with
silicon valley bank, with
signature bank, the problems
that we've seen with regional
banks are not necessarily
connected to what is happening
with Credit Suisse.
But they're positive with the
fact that there has been a mood
shift in how people are viewing
the sector, therefore any
problem can create a risk
particularly in one in a bank as
large as Credit Suisse.
So U.S. Officials have been
monitoring through Credit Suisse
throughout the course of the
day.
They've been talking on a pretty
regular basis with their
counterparts in Europe as well
trying to make sure that the
spillover risk is limited.
And if there is spillover risk,
they're cognizant of that fact.
Try to make clear, these are
separate issues, but, Jake, a
general sense of the market of
the anxiety, and they need to be
prepared for anything that may
come next.
>> Phil, has all of this had
officials question whether they
did enough three days ago from
stop this from exacerbating?
>> Well, what's interesting, in
conversations I've had
throughout the day, the short
answer is, no.
The tools they put in place,
both back stopping the uninsured
deposits, well as the insured
deposits at the two banks.
And to other lenders that may
fail as well.
Trying to ensure confidence in
depositors, over the course of
the last through days that, they
feel, has started to take hold.
The limited facility they've set
up at the federal reserve has
created options for lines of
banks most stressed at this
point.
They feel those were the right
tools.
It's worth noting they were very
significant emergency
interventions put on the table.
And what's happening with credit
Suisse right now doesn't change
their view that those are the
right answers.
I do believe, in talking to
these officials, again, as we've
been discussing, they are
cognizant of the fact that the
real problem they face at this
moment in time is perception, is
panic.
People's perception of risk, as
this continues to play out, even
if they don't think necessarily
these institutions are
connected, these particular
problems are connected.
If the view becomes that the
system is unstable, that it
doesn't matter what capital bank
is holding or what the
regulations are in place, then
they have very big problems that
can spread very quickly.
If you look at the equities
markets, Jake, and you look at
the biggest banks taking a hit
right now, JPMorgan or bank of
America, on the equity side,
that does not track with how
everything is going over the
last several days.
Most of the major deposits have
been going to the banks.
They feel they're substantial
and yet, they've taken a hit.
All of this drives to the idea
that there's a shifting in the
marketplace right now.
A very real concern about risks,
a very real concern about
constagen and spillover effects.
They feel what will they've put
in place can manage what they're
dealing with at home.
But they know things can spread.
And very aware of that fact and
I think prepared for that fact
as well, Jake.
>> Presumably, Phil, the
administration is discussing
whether or not congress should
step in and legislate, tell us
about that.
>> When you talk to
administration officials they
say two things when it comes to
the regulatory side and whether
or not they'd need emergency
action from capitol hill.
One, the president has talked
about regulation and perhaps
putting back in place the 2018
regulations that were eased on
smaller banks under president
trump.
That is something that does not
seem to have any pathway forward
nor any immediate effect of what
we're watching and dealing with
now, when it comes to capitol
hill with emergency infusion of
cash there aren't a lot of
conversations, in part because
it's a recognition of a
political environment and
government where Republicans
have stated opposition what
happened over the weekend.
Almost all of whom are deeply
opposed to what happened back in
2008.
So there's no real move to doing
something like that.
Plus, they don't think that's
necessitated at this point in
time based on what they're
seeing.